I made a very big mistake in Portland
well there was a woman who I mean I'm
sorry a man who came to his show and he
was he was trans and I made I didn't
know that you're not supposed to ask
them this but you know he used to be a
woman and I asked him like do you plan
on getting the surgery but I asked it
discreetly not around Bobby but she he
yelled at me he basically you're not
allowed to ask that like that's very
rude like she basically gave me a
schooling and I I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
so sorry like I didn't know cuz it's
just it's my but it's my innocent
curiosity because I really do like you
know I haven't it was just my curiosity
but I didn't and I learned a lesson
you're not supposed to doing about a new
law in this country and I've been
thinking about this myself okay is that
if you know somebody as a dude right for
like 30 years and then they become they
change come o woman you still get to
call them what you called them why just
because it's like that you want to help
I want to call you Bruce not Caitlyn
Bruce but you want your friends to be
happy right yeah but from then on anyone
that he meets as Caitlyn Jenner they
have to call him jatin jit Caitlyn
Caitlyn I will do anything that makes
them happy all right forget the law then
target don't pass it but don't put it
yeah okay yeah you're right because if
your brother a transition and he said
Bob it's really important you call Kelly
call me Shelly Bobby oh my god what
would I do and your sister now I'll go
alright wait girl yeah yeah so every
time I would call a little angry that's
not supportive bar I don't care speed
yeah yeah I mean I would just be angry
about it let me tell you something right
now
my parents would not go for it I think
your mom might know what mother always
right no I would tell by pulled Shelly
aside look at me
okay I know you're gonna get this
surgery and I know that you're all over
no but you can't tell mom and dad until
they die wait you can't
you can tell her before you can't tell
them ever oh I don't want them that I
don't want the laughs not there's
something wrong with it I'm supportive
of people that want to go trans and
stuff it's because that's who you are
but my parents are old-school Korean and
they're just at the end of the line I
just don't want that and one last thing
at the end have having to deal and they
already dealt with my brother Nuys drug
addiction and our rebellious Ness and
our fucked-up things and now that you
know it's that we've like come through
for them you know like my brother's
they're taking care of them yeah you
know I'm there for them financially
they're proud of us I just don't want
one next thing last thing to make them
feel weird about Earth and their lives
know is that wrong for me I think that's
that's what's for tea he's my bro I mean
yeah but Caitlin came out old changed
when he was 60s so yeah I mean could
happen at any time yeah yeah but you
already know little you'll get they'll
leave you little bread crumbs along the
way they didn't know like no I don't
think I don't think Lloyd Kardashian on
them don't knew that oh bomb yeah they
did because the younger kids would catch
Bruce Jenner cross-dressing and they
just never said anything and they would
find women's stuff that didn't belong to
their mom and they thought that he was
cheating on her oh so he had been across
he wanted to transition way back in the
80s I never stood on this reality show
though right and apparently Kris Jenner
had some idea like she knew this wasn't
like she wasn't completely blindsided
you know she wasn't she just didn't know
that he was gonna actually like
transition fully and get the the t
blockers you know they get the boob job
and all of that yeah I mean I we saw
before I saw the Boston bombing thing I
saw or afterwards I saw a little
documentary about trans trans trans on
HBO also and yeah I mean I believe I
believe that some people are born you
know in the wrong body I get it I do and
even if I didn't get it I would still
believe them yeah respek even if I was
like you know I don't know about that
but you know they believe it and they
want to do it I support them fully
that's the thing I don't underst
and about conservative people that they
can't have that mind frame of like all
right I don't really believe that gay
people should be married but do your
thing if they want to just do it if that
makes you happy you know just why don't
they have that why do I have that
[Music]